the Nintendo NX releases next year but
we still haven't officially seen the
console or heard much about what games
it'll have but according to a report
from MCV the console will have a strong
early lineup quote sources close to
Nintendo say it will have super mario
legend of zelda and pokemon games within
six months of launch we already knew
Zelda breadth of the wild was coming to
both wii u and n eggs but the idea of a
new Mario near launch is exciting
gamefreak bringing Pokemon to the system
also sounds interesting though it's
unclear if this is related to Sun and
Moon which launches on 3ds this fall
MCBs report also mentions support from
third parties like Sega Square Enix
Ubisoft Activision and Warner Brothers
sounds like the NX will come out of the
gate swinging Nintendo has already
confirmed that the NX launches in March
2017 so you can expect to see an
official reveal in the near future in
the meantime you can head to gamespot
for all the latest NX info as it
trickles in for all the biggest nintendo
news you already in the right place